happy holidays Youtubers, it's Charlie so
we got new alien covenant footage let's break
it down there but like open their face hugger
present for Christmas, this is so funny their
whole bunch other trailers that are coming
this week.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Make sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss out you can kinda see what
they're doing here.
There's a lot of the first three aliens movies
in this mostly from the first alien movie
and then James Cameron's aliens like you know
Colonial Marines more action.
The first alien film was sort of like this
silent horror thriller there was a little
more atmospheric like you have the crew of
this freighter land on this derelict planet
and then they discover the alien egg in it
all just unfolds and goes to ship in aliens
it's more of a bug hunt like you actually
have military people on board their going
to help a bunch of colonists clear out the
aliens they know little bit more about them.
So for those you asking about where this takes
place in the timeline.
This is a direct sequel to Prometheus.
So there are two versions of Michael Fassbender
in here.
There's the one with Dr. Elizabeth Shaw that
escaped at the end of the film to go find
the builders home world like look were there
signal was coming from and then the crew of
this new spaceship has their own more advanced
version of his model.
So you to remember he's in android made by
the Whalen Corporation.
So this new spaceship.
It's called the covenant that you of the movie
is called alien covenant covenant is the name
of their spaceship like you hear them freaking
out is the alien starts to burst out of the
guys back.
So the pitch is is that bound for a remote
planet on the far side of the galaxy the crew
of the colony ship covenant find what they
believed to be an uncharted paradise with
the crew discovers is a dark dangerous world
whose sole inhabitant is the synthetic David
Michael Fassbender survivor of the doomed
Prometheus expedition.
So it sounds like what happened at the end
of Prometheus when they took off they eventually
crashed on this planet.
We don't know where Dr. Elizabeth Shaw is,
but she's on the cast list, so she might be
in like a prologue she might be dead.
When this crew lands on the planet she might
be somewhere else but now you kinda see based
on the pitch in the circumstances that they
find themselves in this is very much the first
alien film in the second aliens film so sort
of the Sigourney Weaver of this movie is Catherine
Waterson which is funny because she was the
person she was like the main actors from fantastic
beasts.
So this is what she looked like in that movie
this is what she looks like in this movie
in a very Sigourney Weaver very bad as I can't
wait to see is going to be a lot of fun.
She looks more like Sigourney Weaver in the
second movie and aliens.
Like when she was running around in the tank
top with the giant gun and in the first movie
when she was still just like the regular crewmember
just trying to figure everything out.
So like I said this is a prequel to the first
alien film.
So they still have Apsley no idea what's going
on with the Xena morphs but presumably David
from Prometheus will inform them because he
remembers everything that happened like you
given the data that they need.
Walter is the new version of the android like
the bishop version like you went from Ian
Holmes version that glitched out try to kill
everyone of the first alien film to the more
advanced trustworthy Bishop the funny thing
is is because this is all happening before
Ian Holmes model is been created may be will
see one of these androids glitch out for those
you asking about James Franco he is in the
movie.
We don't know who he's playing this kind of
looks like him a little bit he could be the
guy that hasn't alien bursting out of his
back should be pretty bad ass like in a very
small role, but very and say that feels like
something that James Franco would be on board
for Billy crud up is the one that looks down
into the egg.
It looks like he gets the face hugger treatment.
So this is a bit confusing this actor does
not look like him.
So it sounds like a couple people will get
bay suckers in the movie but here's the big
question do you think that this mysterious
alien paradise the turns out to be this terrible
terrible planet is the actual planet from
the first alien film do you think that's what
they're trying to imply because the race of
builders seated all kinds of planets like
that and just see a couple planets, including
Earth that was what really Scott was trying
to say and Prometheus that there was this
race of aliens that was trying to see the
galaxy with life a bunch of different planets,
so the space Jockey ship from the first alien
film is just one of many ships that they have.
So I'll be really interested to see if that's
what the cases because supposedly in the first
alien film the Whalen Corporation had knowledge
of this alien planet in the Xena morphs so
part of the mystery was when Ian Holm was
communicating with the computer talking to
the Whalen Corporation back home and they
were like no stay we want you to find out
what's going on instead of bailing out like
the rest of the crew wanted.
So you don't really learn more about their
purpose until the second aliens film like
the Whalen Corporation wants to weapon eyes
the Xena morphs so that sort of falls over
time as they learn more and more about them.
So we might see some of that teased in this
movie but it looks great.
It looks a lot better than Prometheus Prometheus
was okay but overall I think the first two
aliens films are just vastly superior to everything
else.
So that's another great question let me know
what your favorite alien film from the franchise
and what you think about them dropping this
on Christmas I just think it's so funny that
they dropped it like midnight on Christmas
but in related news there is a lot of other
comic book stuff happening this weekend I'm
dropping some best of comic book holiday stories
as well.
As Justice league trailer that we haven't
got any confirmation on when that is coming
Henry cavill just posted this picture of him
hanging out with the rock mysteriously on
Christmas like he's literally saying that
he in the rock or just hang out DC worlds
collide he calls out black Adam by name and
what a coincidence that people were saying
that there is a Justice league trailer dropping
the weekend of Christmas and we see the DC
illuminati just happening to meet and hang
out with each other at the same time to just
be on high alert for Justice league trailer
stuff.
It might come Monday it might come a little
bit later but either way I think it's like
right around the corner and that's why all
these DC people reading behind-the-scenes
soul talk a little bit more about that the
next time I post a DC video.
But I'm also working on some Doctor Who Christmas
special in the be some Sherlock next week
for those you that are asking about that to
what you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my flash and Justice league
save Christmas video and you can click here
for my last big Justice league teaser breakdown.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you guys tonight!